And now it's the old scout master.
All right,
So you know you listen to the podcast. you hear the joke at the beginning of the
podcast. you might not repeat it because, frankly, some of them are pretty bad.
This isn't really a joke, but it's funny.
I heard a YouTube video of our chief scout executive, Bob Mazooka,
giving a speech
And one of the things he said was meetings don't have to be eternal to be
immortal.
I mean, we'd love to have meetings.
We have committee meetings,
We have all kinds of meetings. right?
Meetings don't have to be eternal to be immortal.
Hey, you'll have a good chance of using that somewhere this week, right?
Hey, this podcast number 94..
Hey,
Welcome back to the scout master podcast.
This is Clark Green.
So, uh, looking into the mailbag, Bill Daniel got in touch with us this week.
He said thanks for your tremendous effort and output.
I'm a new listener via iTunes on my iPhone.
iTunes seems to have a random selection of your podcasts.
I'd like to get them all onto my iPhone.
Can you give a newbie some technical help?
And then I also heard from Jeff Berg.
He says I've been listening to all your podcasts from the very beginning.
I appreciate all the great ideas and thought provoking conversations you have.
When I got to podcast number 11, though
it was an incomplete session,
Is there any chance it could be reposted or emailed so that I can listen to the rest
of the story?
I've got like a very basic familiarity with the way that iTunes works.
Um, what I'm working on right now is a some way of archiving the podcast
on the website so that they can easily be downloaded to your mobile device
or to- uh, you know- your computer
If you want to listen to them later. I know there's a lot of you out there
who are kind of working through the backlog.
Um, this is podcast 94.
So you got a lot of catching up to do. if you're doing that,
If you do come across something like Jeff dead with podcast number 11,
let me know and I'll get it fixed.
And I think we got number 11 fixed now too.
Rick Pushey has also wrote that he is the publisher of his local
council newsletter and that's the Las Padres Council in Santa Barbara,
California, and they feature a monthly website in the newsletter
And they did a scoutmastercgcom this month with the podcast and everything.
So thank you very much, Rick, for doing that
And, um, hey, everybody out there in Las Padres Council in Santa Barbara.
Uh, drop me a line.
Let me know that you heard me.
Uh, Steve Boone wrote in. he said last week he talked about
scoutmaster projects and scouts using them to fulfill their leadership
requirements for star in life.
That was back in podcast number 93..
I'm a fairly new scoutmaster in Winston Salem, North Carolina.
I'm trying to start a new position within our troop called the Game Master.
The scout would be responsible for coming to our regular meetings
15 minutes early and having a game prepared for any scouts who want
to come early and play.
It seems similar to an instructor position, but he'd be instructing
games instead of like scout skills.
Uh, and you always need to have a game ready.
Steve, that's a pretty interesting idea:
Work with the scouts at their level, find out what they need,
what they want, and then help them discover a way to make that happen.
If it, if it's coming up with something called a Game Master,
Hey, sounds great to me.
Um, you won't get a patch for it, but, uh, it sounds like a good
scoutmaster assigned leadership project. over on the blog this week.
Uh, we talked about several things.
We've uh had a series about social media and scouting and
we're going to expand on that a little bit in uh scoutmaster
ship in seven minutes or less.
And we've also got a survey going about Weebel as transitions-
very short survey.
Go to scoutmastercgcom and look for the Weebel as transition
survey. just a few questions about how you manage Weebel as
transition, uh, what you think uh needs to be fixed in your
particular situation.
We're getting ready to record our next scoutmaster panel
discussion in a week or so.
Uh send your question to scoutmastercg at Verizonnet by
email and we might choose you to be part of the recording
session and have uh be able to ask your question live and uh
get some responses, have a little dialogue with the, with
the scoutmaster panel.
So the rest of this show, let's see. we are going to talk
about social media and scouting.
We're going to uh play a email question from the
archives and this was back in scoutmaster podcast number four.
So uh, it was a while back and the recording quality is
not what it is today, but I think it's good enough to
listen to and that should be enough for this podcast.
So let's get started.
Shall we scoutmastership in seven minutes or less.
Our scouts are what are called digital natives
Now. in other words, they don't know a world without
computers. in the internet,
You and I are likely to be, uh, what's called digital
immigrants.
We were raised and educated in an era before digital
technology or during its emergence,
And, um, if you want to learn more about that, I
recommend an article that uh writer and educator,
Mark Penske, wrote in uh back about 10 years ago,
And I will have a link to the PDF version of that
article on the uh post that contains this podcast.
All these wonderful technologies have definitely
altered our lives and we can sing their praises or
we can complain about them,
But I want to talk about social media for a moment.
Social media is a word that's banner about, and
I'm going to talk about social media tools.
My definition of social media tools may be a
little bit different from the general definition
out there, because I include everything that we
use to interact on the web.
I basically have it broken down into three
different categories.
There's these general publication outlets.
I define that as anything where you create the
content, you put it online and you wait for
people to read it.
Uh, websites are the most familiar tool for
publishing information.
Uh, they're kind of static and it's content
that does not necessarily change very often
Blogs like scoutmastercgcom blog is
web and log together and that publishes
content on an ongoing basis or as posts or
individual articles.
Podcasts, like the one you're listening to
right now, can be video or audio, but these
are general publication tools that basically
put stuff out there and people can respond
and interact with them in different ways.
There are social networks, too.
Social networks are a whole other class of
a web application, like Facebook and Google
Plus and MySpace and all of those
Uh, and they allow a really broad general
interaction.
They're more of a conversational type of thing.
These tools are more of a group meeting place,
Um. and then there are personal networks
and these are generally used for one-on-one
exchanges of information without any real
outside monitoring, and you know the most
familiar personal network is email.
Uh, texting is also one of these personal
networks.
So, basically, you know, that's kind of my-
probably imperfect- way of breaking this down-
There are the general publishing tools
like websites, the social networks like
Facebook, and then the personal networks
that are more of a closed loop, like email
and texting and things like that.
One of the more remarkable things about all
this social, all these social media tools,
is that they change seemingly from day to
day.
Sometimes it seems like from hour to hour,
Uh, the rules change,
The way that they work changes, uh, the
way that you can interconnect to them
And, uh, cross publish things changes.
It's. it's at once an amazing and
potentially frustrating type of thing.
If we go back 10 or 15 years, to when the
internet was just emerging and it became
a household thing and everybody started
using it, what happened with scouting?
Well, everybody wanted to have a website
for their particular corner of the
scouting world.
If you had a troop or a pack, you know,
if you were part of an order of the
air lodge or council or a district,
hey, we need to have a website.
Well, why do we need to have a website?
Well, everybody has a website.
I mean, we have to have a website,
right,
And you know, a lot of time and
effort went into putting websites
together.
Uh, there were wonderful people who
put resources online- you know
different program resources and things
like that- and established those types
of websites,
And I think we found it all very useful.
There are some very basic underlying
concepts to all this that you probably
know, but it's something that I think
we need to constantly remind ourselves
of and it's something we need to
remind our scouts about
That is, whenever we are working online
with any of these social media tools,
we cannot assume privacy.
If it's typed into a computer, set
into a microphone, set into a cell
phone, if it's texted, if it's a
picture, if it's a movie, it's
traceable and public
And it will never, ever go away.
I think that has to be understood.
Once we put anything into digital
form, it is, for all intents
and purposes, permanent,
And we have to consider that whenever
we're using one of these social
media tools. there's also some
unique challenges to using
social media stemming from issues
of youth protection.
The BSA has an excellent set of
principles for using social
media and outline of how to use
it safely and how to apply youth
protection principles to it,
And I'll have a link to that in the
post that contains this podcast.
But it's really pretty simple,
because the central concept of our
youth protection policy is that
there is no one-on-one contact
between youth and adults.
It's always monitored,
And so we need to extend that into
the virtual world. when we are
emailing scouts or when we are
working with them online
through a social media outlet,
It cannot be an exclusively one-on-
one communication.
It needs to be monitored.
And that's very, very simple to do.
You just have to include a third
person in any conversation
you're having with a youth
member,
And that's pretty simple.
The way that I handle it with
email: if I'm having an email
conversation with a scout, I
carbon copy my troop committee
chair
And if he's having a
conversation with a scout, he
carbon copies me.
It's an understanding. sometimes
we get messages and you
know they're not for us to act
on, they're just for us to
monitor.
Finally, I think there's one
thing that the use of these
social media tools is not going
to change:
The concept of closing the
communication loop. one of
our biggest challenges as
scout leaders still remains
communicating with scouts and
their families and with scouts
being able to communicate back
and forth with each other.
And if you don't close that
loop, if there's not some
kind of reply in that
communication, then it's no
fair. It's no fair to put
something on a website and
you know say, OK, I've tagged
you with the information.
You should have read the
website. you know, shame on
you, and then that's not
going to work.
It's no fair to put something
in an email and just send it
out to everybody and say, well,
hey, I put it in an email
tagged you with the
information you're it now.
That's no fair,
And the reason it's no
fair is because these are
very imperfect systems.
Maybe 80% of your scouts
and their families will read
the email or look on the
website, and that would be
a really high percentage.
But there's, but there's always
going to be, people who do not
read an email,
They don't look on the
website and they get left out.
So the gold standard is
closing the loop of
communication
And you know, the only way
you can do that is
communicating with people
one on one,
And the standard for
communication these days, if
we're not standing toe to
toe and talking to people
is is using the telephone.
You know, even leaving a phone
message, that's not closing
the loop.
The loop has not been closed.
So the onus is still on us
to make sure we close the loop
of communication and we talk to
people. Social media cannot
do that. A website cannot
do that. Emails cannot
really do that.
So I can tell you what the
evolution of using these
tools has been for our troop.
You know we thought that,
first of all, having a
website was a really cool idea
and we spent a lot of time
designing it and putting it
up. And it was. it had all
kinds of bells and whistles
on it and nobody paid any
attention to it whatsoever.
You know, I mean five of
us thought it was really cool
but it wasn't very useful.
We've tried email lists and
groups and calendars online
and things like that
And there's no magic bullet.
All these things are only
supplementary to a good, solid,
closed loop communication
system And that's always
going to be picking up the
telephone. There's really
no other way to make it
happen. So we have
now a hosted website
and it sends out a weekly
email newsletter and that
seems to work pretty well.
I think probably about 75
to 80 percent of our
families actually read that
newsletter. But the
gold standard still personal
telephone call patrol
leaders call every week
and they make sure they
close the loop of communication
and let scouts know what's
going on. And we net and
that's the way that families
get to know what's going on.
So those are my thoughts
about social media.
There is a series of four
articles online at
scoutmastercgcom
if you'd like to expand on
this, And I'd love to
hear your thoughts and your
impressions and how you
use social media tools in
your association with
scouting.
Cliff Jacobson and you're
listening to the Scoutmaster
podcast with Clark Green
Email, that is folks.
And here's an answer to one of
your emails
From Mark Bowie, scoutmaster
of troop five three, one
in Orange, California.
He says: hello, Clark,
I enjoy your thoughtful blogs
and podcasts. Well, thank you,
Mark, and I'm interested to
learn about your views on
Meribaj days. Now, what I'm
understanding is Meribaj day
is kind of like a Meribaj
college or any kind of an
event where multiple Meribajs
are offered with
counselors attached.
I know our local museum
near us offers two or three
Meribajs a couple three
days a year and Scouts can
come in and as a group they
can work their way through
the Meribaj.
He says your podcast item
about Ben Powell's view on
badge hunters versus badge
earners was timely
And we have recently been
having a debate in our
troop about Meribaj days.
One side says that the
primary purpose is to raise
money for the hosting
troop
And I don't really know
how that works, but I'll
accept the fact that
somewhere out there our troop
is hosting a Meribaj day and
they might be doing it as a
fundraiser and not to ensure
quality instruction for the
boys and that they're only a
short kind of Meribaj
completion.
Others say that in today's
business schedule is too hard
to find Meribaj counselor
and schedule meetings with
them to review progress,
And that Meribaj days are
the only practical way, outside
of summer camp, to complete.
Meribaj is what do you
think?
Well, I'm going to stand
directly in the middle
Because I agree.
I agree with both sides to a
certain extent.
So let me explain myself.
First of all, Meribaj is.
there's a very simple system
and there's a very simple
rules about who gets
involved. where the boy brings
you a blank blue card,
Mr Scout master,
He says: I am going to do
scouting, you know, camping
Meribaj, and I would ask
who is your counselor?
And I would say: is he a
certified counselor?
And if I needed to check up
on that, I would use what
resources I needed to make
sure that this was a
registered Meribaj counselor
and I would possibly review
with the boy the youth
protection
specifications around. Meribaj
is that there are no one
on one meetings with
adults. in other words, bring
a scout with you or there
needs to be a second
adult present
And then I would pat him
on his head and send him
on his happy way.
Several days, weeks, months
later, he will bring me
a completed blue card
I will tell him to take it
to the advancement chairman
or the troops scribe,
and then the troops scribe
or the advancement chairman
will hand me the blue card
to sign at one point
And I will hand
the scout a Meribaj
at our earliest convenience
and shake his hand
and congratulate him
for a job well done.
Now, nowhere in there,
nowhere in that very
simple process, does the
scout master interfere
with who the counselor is,
if it's a registered
Meribaj counselor,
the rigor of the study
of the Meribaj or the quality
of the instruction
of work that a scout
does with the Meribaj.
I see only blue cards.
I see happy scouts.
I hand out Meribaj's.
if for some reason,
I was to become concerned
about the instruction
of a given Meribaj,
or I was to become
concerned that, you know,
somebody was just giving
Meribaj's away,
which is a concern
that's often expressed,
but in 25 years
I have never, ever seen anybody
giving Meribaj's away-
Then I would take that concern
to the people who are
certifying Meribaj counselors,
because it is not the scouts fault
if the Meribaj counselor
is not doing his job.
It's the Meribaj counselor's fault.
Who certifies Meribaj counselors?
Well, your council advancement
committee does,
and your district advancement committee
and that would be the person
I would take the concerns to.
If you really think,
if people are
really thinking that these
Meribaj days, as you call them,
are just shortcuts,
and take it to the next level
and ask what kind of quality
control is being done
for the counselors
that are operating there
and things like that.
Otherwise, keep your nose out
and let the scouts go
and do and achieve
A Meribaj is not a certificate
of completion of a course
of rigorous study.
I got to tell you, a scout
with life-saving Meribaj
is not a qualified lifesaver,
nor is a scout
with first aid Meribaj and EMT.
Those kind of certifications
require far more rigorous study.
First aid Meribaj
and life-saving Meribaj are valuable
and they're a valuable set of skills,
But we would never depend on them
as a sole indication
of somebody's skill level,
maturity and their ability
to handle a situation
that a lifeguard or an EMT
would handle, would we?
Now I am going to differ
with the others
that say in today's busy schedules
it's too hard to find a Meribaj counselor
in schedule meetings
and things like that.
Well, we have things like email.
I have done significant parts
of Meribaj's that I counsel
with email.
My inner drill sergeant
would like to see more rigor
in study
and more rigor
in the instruction of Meribaj's.
but understanding what Meribaj's represent,
what they're supposed to represent
and how scouts
will have learned a little something
about a given field of study
or endeavor.
I'm quite satisfied
with the way that the system works.
I will have a little internal dialogue
with the internal drill sergeant
and I will say: you know,
it's not that big a deal.
Baden Powell said something
about the jollity of scouting.
Jollity is not a word
that you hear a whole lot,
but you know
Baden Powell was born in 1857,
so let's cut him a break.
That indicates to me
a certain amount of lightness
and fun
and intensity and excitement
surrounding the work of scouting.
I wouldn't be too upset
about the Meribaj days.
I kind of agree.
I'm a little suspicious
of the whole thing.
I'm suspicious of, you know,
30 guys and a 16-year-old counselor
trying to complete swimming
Meribaj at camp.
Just how rigorous and complete
can the instruction be
in that kind of a situation?
But it's been going on for years
and you know I'm satisfied
that the guys have gotten out of it
what they need to get out of it.
These are not my badges to protect.
They're not my standards to protect.
I have yet to embroider
hand, embroider a Meribaj
and hand it out at a court of honor.
We go and buy them
from the Boy Scouts of America
who own the Meribaj
and who own the program,
And I will
assent to the way
that they're going to administer it,
even though, even though
the inter-drill sergeant,
may have some difficulties with it.
So I hope that helps you, Mark,
And if you need more clarification
on that, do drop me a line.
Well, thanks for listening to this
edition of the Scoutmaster Podcast.
Now here's how to keep in touch.
You can read the Scoutmaster blog
at scoutmastercgcom.
While you're there,
you can subscribe to the
Scoutmaster Newsletter
and you can also subscribe
to this podcast on iTunes
When you do feel free to leave
a comment or review or a rating.
You can also access the podcast
on your mobile device
through Stitcher Smart Radio,
and you can get details about
that at Stitchercom.
You can call and leave a voicemail
comment or question at
484-734-0002..
And you can also experience
the wonders of ScoutmasterCGcom
through the vast panorama
of social media outlets.
That's right.
You can follow us at
ScoutmasterBlog on Facebook.
You can tweet us at
ScoutmasterCG on Twitter
and, for admittance to the
exclusive ScoutmasterCG circle,
search for ScoutmasterCG
on Google Plus.
You can email me,
Clark Green, with your
comments and questions
and wild ideas at
ScoutmasterCG at Verizonnet.
Now I need to tell you
that this podcast is
not an official publication
of the Boy Scouts of America,
No, and it's not endorsed
by the Boy Scouts of America.
Now, it's just me.
I found a microphone
and a computer
and I figured this out,
and I want to help
scout leaders and have
a little bit of fun
along the way as well.
So, our founder,
Baden Powell, Sir Robert,
have you anything for us this week?
Good luck to you
and group camping.
Why? thank you, sir,
Until next time.